[Music]
hello friends we are so happy to be with
you here in this program i'd like to
know
i really like this program because we
get different questions we have the
opportunity to go to the bible in depth
and trying to answer these questions for
you thank you for sending your questions
i am here with my dear pastor c.a murray
associate speaker of secrets and seal it
is a pleasure to have you here always
good to be with you then and before we
begin i would like to remind you that if
you want to
send your questions you can do it so
through the following email address tv
at some
tv.org this is tb
at some tb dot org
we have a big pile of questions as you
can see
so
if we don't if we do not answer your
question right away
this is the reason
but if we see that there is a question
that needs to be answered
uh that is a priority and that is a very
very important timely question although
all the all the questions are really
good
we will give priority to those questions
so
we will not always follow the same order
but we'll try to do so
before we begin i would like to ask a
pastor c murray to
lead us in operating prayer we're glad
to do so shall we pray father god again
we thank you and praise you
for the opportunity to study your word
there is power
in your word you honor your word above
your name
you have told us you have instructed us
that we need to feed on the word and
we thank you for the questions that have
come in we thank you for the opportunity
to study we thank you that
your word is a lamp unto our feet and a
light into our path and we are thankful
lord that when we study your word we are
brought closer to the mind of jesus amen
so bless all that we say
during this program be the center and
circumference of all that is said and
done so that christ is seen
glorified and lifted up and we thank you
for your promise to hear and answer the
prayer of faith in jesus name amen amen
amen
okay so
our first question
actually there were two people that
wrote on the same question so we're
going to answer these questions at the
same time
one comes from china
and i don't know how to read the name
but i in the email it says howard so
this is i guess this is the name brother
howard
he is uh greeting us from
china
and he is wishing us happy new year
happy new year to you too
in this question
he says
i'd like to know
if a woman can give a sermon on the
sabbath day
so that is the basic question
and the other question is basically the
same question but also has to do when
what
has to do with when women can
participate in worship
if they can lead prayer if they can give
sermons if they can do the bible
reading
or the scripture reading
should they participate only on the
sabbath day or can they preach during
the week so these are basically the same
questions that we have here
and brother howard
he gives some verses
that
apparently
sustain the idea that women are not
supposed to preach for example first
timothy 2 11
then first corinthians 14 34 and 35
and first corinthians chapter 11 verses
to 10.
so
i believe this ministry has a lot of
material on
the role of women in the church women's
ordination but we'll try to answer this
question very briefly
in regards to can a woman give a sermon
on
the sabbath day
so pasamura do you have some thoughts on
that you know it is interesting that
this question comes from china and i
think that is one of the reasons that
occasions this question
because there are a number of
congregations in china
recognized by the church where women are
leading out
uh
they are doing so because there is a
shortage of men
who are available
uh to take that role right and
so they are stepping forward
we have we have a couple issues that
we're dealing with one is a woman
speaking in church
and the other is a woman exercising
pastoral authority yes
they they are i don't believe the self
same issue
i know
many women uh
who speak in church
some of them are my very close friends
though they do not assume the pastoral
authority
should women speak in church now um i
want to go to first corinthians he's got
let's say 14 34 and 35
um here
let your women keep silent in the
churches for their but not permission to
speak
this does not
deal with um
they're not speaking at all exactly this
this is uh
one of the things you've got to realize
when you think when you're pulling texts
from the book of corinthians
corinthians is written to a church in
turmoil
so
when you are
including those statements that that
that talk about tongues and those other
things you're dealing with the church
he's trying to correct problems right uh
so you're dealing with a church that has
some significant problems in the way it
handles itself
so this woman not speaking in church is
not talking about uh official pulpit
speaking it's talking about yelling out
and other kinds of things that are
problematic in this particular church so
be very careful when you try to apply
corinthian
instruction to the whole church of god
because he's dealing with a particular
set of problems that that are
inherent to the corinthians
that's true and actually verse 35 of the
same chapter
um
gives us the context of what paul means
when he says that women are not
permitted to speak is this referring to
the
giving of the word of god precisely not
no because in verse 35 it says
but if they want to learn something let
them ask their own husbands at home
for it is shameful for women to speak in
the church yeah i i should have finished
it all and i'm glad you did
thank you for getting my back on that
because basically the problem was
people asking
questions um
in the middle of a service exactly yeah
and of course um
it is thought and and probably so that
that men and women did not sit together
in church so if a woman wanted a certain
learn something from her husband she's
yelling across the church
daniel
what's he talking about you know
and especially because there were some
that wanted to to preach in tongues
precisely i don't understand so you can
see the the the chaos the the of
caffeine if people are asking questions
across the aisles and those kind of
things um so
this is the context for these these
particular statements not that women
should not uh uh speak in in the church
at all but this kind of thing this kind
of chaos should not be countenance so
the context is order and
um
[Music]
yeah order and reverence in the house of
god
in the hour of worship so this is
nothing that this doesn't have anything
to do with preaching
now
there is a more problematic text
that he quotes here from first timothy
to 11 yes
because that one seems to imply
that they should not teach or preach
it says here first timothy 2 11 let a
woman learn in silence with all
submission in verse 12 it says and i do
not permit a woman to teach or to have
authority over a man
but to be in silence i think the key
word here to understand what paul is
trying to talk about is to have
authority
authority so as you mentioned pastor ca
at the beginning of this question
the issue here is not about preaching or
not preaching is about women having
ecclesiastical authority and the context
supports that because what we see in the
next chapter
is
the roles or the qualifications of
bishops or ministers pastors
so it is in the context of these
authority that we find in ver in chapter
that paul says i do not permit women to
teach or have authority over a man but
to be
in silence
but this doesn't have anything to do
with with preaching we see
uh
for example if we come
um earlier in our history this history
of our pioneers ellen white herself she
preached many sermons on the sabbath day
and many other women
so
we don't have any problem with that
no
the thing is exercising
pastoral or or
later on we see
the role of elder defined uh
in in the church of god but to speak for
the lord and of course
all
our authority comes from the word of god
when when when christ spoke as one
having authority uh
you know
included in that is is is in in the
greek understanding is master ability
capability capacity force um whatever
power our words have
come to us not from our stature or
standing they they are inherent in the
word of god yes so if a woman speaks
with authority it is not
her authority it's the authority of the
word of god and as long as she's in the
word of god the authority is is there
but uh the separate issue is is
pastoral authority uh and that is not
what is being dealt with
exactly
and going back to the final text that he
quotes first corinthians 11 verses 3 to
10 yes that actually helps to answer
that question because
i think so yes
for example verse 5
actually says that women can prophesy
so it says
but every woman who prophesies who prays
or prophesies with her head on cover
dishonors her head
for that is one and the same as if her
head were shaved
so the problem here is not with the
woman praying or prophesying no in this
context the problem is the woman they
were prophesying or they were praying
with their head uncovered which was
something particular to the culture that
showed reverence and submission to the
husband precisely so if a woman was
not wearing the veil
that was very
disrespectful for her husband
but uh here paul says a woman can pray
and she can prophesy yes and of course
prophecy here means preaching exactly
yeah it is not always that he's giving a
vision or thing
yeah i mean it means preaching uh in
fact one of the great roles of the
prophet was was preaching was forth
telling it was from foretelling too but
there was a lot of forth telling so uh
we're not talking about prophecy in the
classic sense we're talking about
preaching uh and no problem with that
okay so you know
spiritual things are spiritually
discerned if you take your time with the
word the word opens itself up to you and
explains itself pretty nicely so here we
see the answer to the other question
because
he's not saying don't do that he's
saying don't do it that way that way
right so well done
yes
and as i mentioned at the beginning we
have in our channel
a lot of material on women's ordination
and the role of women so you can
go back and find in our youtube channel
and also on our website a lot of
material that will help clarify those
verses
indeed okay let's go to the our next
question
and this comes from tom v
and the question is why did lot want to
send his two virgin daughters to be gang
raped instead of the two strangers
quoting genesis 19
verse 8.
you know i i re-read
um the story on on sodom
in in ellen white's writings okay and um
you know sometimes you read things and
then you come back two years later and
your mind is in different places i
didn't see that before when i was there
but it's a very interesting story one of
the things that that we find in spirit
of prophecy
is that
a
lot was particularly blessed
by
the way he treated those those strangers
that
had he not insisted on them coming in
she says it was his religious practice
to treat strangers fairly yes to treat
them
amicably he knew the city in which he
lived
he knew the proclivities of the people
and
when the the the uh
strangers resisted initially he said
well come you need to stay at my house
and they said no we're okay we'll stay
in the street
uh and she says
they were testing him yes to make sure
of his sincerity so he insisted no
you're not standing in the street you
need to come inside my house
and it was that insistence on
hospitality that really afforded him the
blessings that were his a little bit
later on a number of things happened in
the train of this but it began with him
insisting that these strangers
uh
come in and had he not done so uh
the way the lord handled it through him
and and what the lord did to him uh
would not have would not have taken
place
right
uh exactly and um
you know the first time i read
genesis 19 8 i also stumbled with that
because
you see here a father that is willing to
give up his two virgin daughters to this
mop and he's trying to protect
the
the strangers the visitors that he had
now recently i was reading something
about
the backgrounds of the old testament
and i learned that it was very
particular in the cultures of the middle
east
to
they were very hospitable
and they would give priority
to those who they were hosting
uh in their home even above their own
families their own family correct so
um
so this was more
of um
what i would say partly cultural
but at the same time lord had learned
from his own uncle
uh abraham to be very hospitable to the
point yeah even being willing to give up
his two
virgin daughters
for them
what is interesting
given the
sensibilities
of
the men
both old and young
in
that town
i don't know if
the daughters were in that much danger
because daughters
was not their intention
they weren't there for daughters
uh
so he he did it
because he he respected his guests
but um and and this is it's a bit
speculative i must say but
the reason we have the the the lesson of
sodom and gomorrah is because of the
things that were happening in sodom and
gomorrah yeah and they weren't
particularly
interested in in women there
uh so he made the offer to try to pacify
this crowd
and their response shows you where their
interests lie we don't care about the
daughters get those guys out here
that's where they were headed and that's
what was of interest to them
but a
lot took
pains to be a hospitable
person as the culture demanded and
illinois says he picked this up from
abraham you know he had been trained
with this
and he just followed his training yes
okay
thank you
we have another question
this one comes from janice bergara
and she says hi pastor bohr
i'd like to know
when do we interpret a text as literal
or spiritual
a friend insists that sabbath now is
spiritual not literal interpreting
matthew 11 28 through 30 and hebrews 4
9.
another reason he believes that sabbath
is not literal
is that we do we don't have a universal
sabbath because of time differences
please help clarify this
text
all right i guess we should read hebrews
and
matthew
to get an idea
i am fairly close to hebrew so i'll grab
that okay
[Music]
you want to read hebrews first yes okay
hebrews chapter four and verse nine
okay
all right here we go
hebrews 4 9.
well
you've got to read eight and nine to
sort of get some context to have it make
sense
um
for if joshua had given them rest
then he would not afterwards have spoken
of another then would not
then he would not afterward have spoken
of another day
there remains therefore a rest
to the people
of god
and then matthew 11 verses 28 through 30
says come unto me only that labor and
are heavy laden and i will give you rest
take my yoke upon you and learn from me
that i am meek and lowly in heart and ye
shall find resting to your souls for my
yoke is easy
and my burden
is
light
okay so
the question then uh has to do with the
sabbath
when do we interpret a text as a literal
and then a spiritual
well overall there is a principle
uh hermeneutical principle when we study
the word of god and is that
the bible should be interpreted as it
reads
unless the context implies that we need
to give it a spiritual or symbolic
meaning to the text okay i want to hit
the pause button just a second that's an
important statement that you just made
you start out
taking it literally
you go to
spiritualizing it when it is demanded
but your primary
the primary way
to interpret the bible
is literally unless it demands something
else so you you start here if
it becomes obvious that you need to move
here then you do so
but you you start if the bible says yey
means yay
it says nay it means nay unless it is
saying something else so you you assume
it means what it says and since we are
not dealing with
any spiritualization in either these two
books
then you've got to assume particularly
matthew
given matthew's mindset the kind of jew
matthew was the literal way matthew
looked at life and
his jewishness
it is not a book like revelation it is
not a book like daniel right matthew
means what he says and says what he
means exactly and of course in hebrews
where the writer is trying to
have the the the jewish community not
revert back to
judaism but to keep on falling after
christ
he again is not spiritualizing he's
saying what he means he means what he
says so there's no
reason to insert a spiritual context in
what are two very literal books
when you're trying to do any kind of
exegesis or understanding what they say
precisely
so it is true
in the case of matthew 11
that
we don't find a direct mention
to the seventh day
but here is
jesus is calling us to come unto him and
experience his rest
but this text
sheds a lot of light on the sabbath rest
because true sabbath rest comes from
jesus from the rest of jesus when we
come to him and uh we find rest unto our
souls
but it is not limited to that spiritual
rest that we find in jesus that we can
find every day but god has particularly
given us
a seventh day sabbath
if we if we under if we try to
understand or we try to explain
all the verses in the bible
that speak on the sabbath and we try to
give it a spiritual interpretation we'll
get in trouble yes because the bible is
very clear when it speaks of the sabbath
of the seventh day that is a literal day
evening and morning 24 hours yes
let's approach it from another angle
you've got 10 commandments
so let's spiritualize
those should not commit adultery
so
um
i see someone i like
and um
since it's just spiritual
i can follow my inclinations spiritual
adultery yes
point being why do we want to
spiritualize that particular commandment
thou shalt not steal
spiritual literal
uh
all of the commandments yeah take them
one through ten we have no problem with
the others being literal why do we want
to spiritualize the one that says
remember the one in which god signs his
name
we would not even know who wrote the
commandments except for god identifying
himself clearly in the fourth
commandment why do you want to
spiritualize that one when we know that
the others are literal and mean what
they say amen
and well
they may say yes that's true in the old
testament we we find it that is is
literal but in the in the new testament
the rest is jesus but we find plenty of
evidences in the new testament that
it is the same day jesus came
not to do away with the law but to
fulfill it he is the lord of the sabbath
he didn't do away with the sabbath and
we see that even the disciples kept the
sabbath after jesus's
crucifixion now one more one more thing
that he mentions or that she mentions
here is that this person
says that
the sabbath is not literal because we
don't have a universal sabbath because
of the time differences but that's not
really a big problem
because the bible says that the sabbath
day begins at sunset on friday yeah so
it doesn't matter where you are in the
world
you will have your 20 or 24 hours of
sabbath rest yes so that would that
wouldn't be a problem yes you know you
you look at luke 4 16 uh christ's habit
was to keep the sabbath um
i like mark 2 28 you know uh 27-28 he is
lord of the seven
as you well said the disciples kept the
sabbath
it's
there are few things in the new
testament that are more concrete
than
the sabbath day when it begins when it
ends and the keeping of the fact jesus
himself referred
to the sabbath
as being observed in the last days
because he says pray that your uh flight
won't be on the winner or the sabbath
day so if you interpret that the
saturday is spiritual you have to
interpret also that that winter is
spiritual
i never quite thought of it that way but
i think that is very very true clearly
jesus is speaking of a literal winter
and he's speaking of a literal sabbath
day
yeah so i think that that the question
is is well answered is very it's very
clear any final thoughts pastor c.a we
are running out of time you know we
we run into this so many many times i've
heard preachers say well god restated uh
nine commandments and he didn't bring
the sabbath through well yes he did
bring the sabbath through not only did
he not
did he state it he lived it out amen uh
in life and in debt
so we know that the sabbath is sure and
uh that it is for all men for all time
amen
well we have come to the end of our
program and we're so thankful that you
have tuned in with us
please keep sending us your questions we
will be more than happy to answer them
remember the email address tv at some tv
dot
org again this is tv at
some tv
dot org we'll be very happy to receive
your questions
and
god bless you this is the end of our
program
and
we will see you next time stay healthy
and stay blessed
[Music]
you